hello everyone and welcome back to the
Women's World Chess Championship between
the well the reigning champion jewel in
June and the Challenger like sonic
record actually not the first 12 games
ended in a draw but not all 12 games
were drawn the match was wrong
but six of the games were decisive I
could actually have won three in June
when June 1 3 so it wasn't like in the
course in Caruana snoozefest and now
they go into the rapid tie break so the
first game of the rapid tiebreaks ended
in a draw
second game also ended in a draw and
this is the third game of the rapids
which I decided to show as it is it is a
very nice game so without further ado
let's check it out and we do have a nice
photo of this matchup there you have it
Knight to f3 is on the board so let's
let's just enjoy that for a second and
let's now show the game so Knight to f3
Baiju in June and we have d5 by gaudí
Akina we have g3 and a c6 strengthening
the center Bishop the g2 end immediately
Bishop to g4 so good actually not wants
to close the course the position while
the light-square bishop is out so you
don't have problems with the development
of the LightSquared bishop later on we
have castles in the Knight to d7 h3
pushing the bishop back Bishop to h5 and
now d4 grabbing a space in the center we
have east 6 now the the cage is closed
that the bishop is nicely out of the
cage and then now c4 we have Bishop to
e7 when we have a trade in the center
see captors it captures and the Knight
to c3 so this has all been played before
and now you have to decide whether we
want to continue 90 G of 6 however you
here are jus in june decides that this
night should not come to e5 because it's
either going to be an excellent outpost
for the night or you can just start
pushing and it's you will have a very
very strong center or you can capture
with the night and then you get d
captures on e5 which will grab more
space in the center for white so here
when June decides to capture on f3 and
here there is one notable game that to
reach this position last year in Prague
dental harikrishna headed against David
navara and Hari Krishna played Bishop
on f3 that game ended in a draw but here
Julian goes for each captures an f3
which really changes the the character
of the position with the well point
points looking the way they look
breaks the pawn chain has three point
islands now but I guess it's something
she prepared and she will test it in a
rapid game against Alexandra Gorge can
and it is as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so garage cannot
continues to develop 90 G to f6 and now
h4 as the light square Bishop is not
doing all that much here and you don't
want to push the F pawn since it nicely
controls the night so the knight cannot
use efore in g4 you want to transfer
your light square bishop to control this
diagonal we have castles by garage
finish up the h3 and now tonight's the
b6 the knight can now come to c4 for
example which will be a nice nice square
Queen to d3 and now rook to e8
continuing development with b3 now
taking away a four end c4 from blacks
night and night F to d7 here you make
room for the bishop to come on f6 but
also you want to remember your knight
via if it there maybe six or g6 later on
so rook to e1 and now Bishop to f6
offering a trade of rooks with Bishop to
b2 so now if black trades you can
recapture with the rook and now a5
starting to expand on the Queen side
with King G to improving the position of
the King a little bit and now Knight the
f8 we have route capture Sonny 8 Queen
captures and now rook to e1 for the
moment winning the e-file Queen back to
d8 and now comes Knight to d1 the knight
is now also being shifted at the e3 from
where you will control g4 and f5 so
Knight B to d7
now with ideas that you can start
further expanding on the Queen side but
also at some point you might also want
to be it might be interested in pushing
c5 we have Knights the e3 and now Queen
to b6 putting pressure on the d4 pawn
and when the night comes the e6 the
night will add even more pressure to the
d4 pawn so Bishop the c3 defending and
the now are a 4 sorry a 4 by black
with the idea that after captions you
might get a nice way to get our rock
lift in so before of course June June
wants to keep the DEA file closed and
now nights the e6 adding a third
attacker to the d4 pawn and here a Jew
in June decides that now it's time to
capture the night so Bishop captures
pawn captures now black gets a stronger
center if black can get a five then he
gets rid of she gets rid of her
well backwards e six pawn so Knight to
g4 now putting pressure on the bishop
but also keeping an eye on the e5 square
we have looked eight preparing e5 but
again f4 preventing it and here Queen
back to d8 now and the queen is not very
useful and b6 so we want to find the
different ways to get her back into the
game and here is as you can see b4 and
the d4 prevent a breakthrough on c5 from
ever happening and it's the same here e5
is nicely controlled so black will never
be able to execute e5 so here you don't
have to really worry about the Queen
side that's closed the center is closed
so it started it's time to start playing
on the King side so h5 we have h6 by
black and then now comes Luke the e3 b5
right away as possible if b5 then for
example capture captures captures you
immediately go after the two weaknesses
but first look the e3 Jew engine says
okay first I'm going to improve the
position of my rook then I'm gonna go
for this breakthrough and as black
doesn't have any breakthroughs or no way
to actually help the helper pieces but
this rook the rook to e3 actually gives
black the chance to play b5 but gray
actually not doesn't go that's gonna
place king - h8 instead and this was a
very valuable moment that b5 move should
have been played so here we have b5 just
with the idea that if captures captures
Queens gonna attack the the b7 point and
the a4 pawn Knights the b8 and now Queen
- E - now putting pressure on the e6
pawn as well see captures on b5 now and
here Queen Catherine b5 you could also
go for captures on f6 first but you know
the
red is stronger than the execution as
they say
so Queen captures nb5 putting pressure
on the dew points here Quintus e8u
cannot defend both of them and now comes
Queen captures on a four so grabbing a
pawn but now Knight to c6 and again
there is some pressure on the d4 pawn
we've pushed back the b2
now with ideas of maybe shifting the
rook over to c3 if needed but also you
can switch this this Bishop that this
diagonal if if you'll need if you'll
need to so rook to e7 now preparing to
meet rooks III would rook to c7 but now
Queen to c2 again pinning the night
since the Queen on uncie it would be
undefended
we have Quinta yet getting out of the
way and also preventing Queen to g6
Queen to g6 would be very dangerous for
example followed by Knight captures on
h6
so now Knight characters on f6g captures
and now Bishop to e3 kicking away the
rook we have worked the g7 and now
finally the breakthrough we have f5 and
okay
a 5 we have D captures F captures and
now f6 a very strong passed pawn and
here rook the g5 may be somewhat more
resilient was rook to g8 but still Queen
f5 threatening f7 and well after you
block Queen f7 now you go Bishop to b2
you go after the pawn and after d4 now
Ruby 3 and it's gonna be hard black
doesn't have useful moves here at some
point you you will be able to bust open
at the center and then well the bishop
will be just too strong for example you
you even have ideas when the position
opens up route captures and b7 for
example Queen captures and then you just
play f7 delivering a deadly check from
the bishop and so on a lot of tactics
and in the position but so good actually
not instead went rook to g5 but now f4
again you cannot capture because rook
captures Queen
so rook captures and h5 was played and
here it's a very very interesting moment
in the game
so because strongest move here is g4
because after rook to h4 you have Queen
to f5 with with a simple threat of just
f7 push the Queen away then Queen f6
share picks up the rook here and then
you'd have to go for this Queen to g8
move f7 attacks the
Queen captures you're gonna trade here
and after.look the g3 is the game over
you either trade and well then get
another queen since the f8 square is
guarded or you capture on f4 but it
doesn't really matter just f8 Queen
captures captures and you are up a whole
rook
so yeah completely winning but the
Juventud calculates absolutely precisely
F captures on e5 and now asks what do
you want to do here here quinta east six
by gaudí Akina now threatening Queen to
h3 and here well it was G although g4
was the absolute best move this is also
winning but with you know you need
surgical precision here or as we like to
call it engine precision so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
winning move for white while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and finding the only move that wins this
game and for those who just want to
enjoy show its king g1 just so Queen h3
doesn't come with the check that's
that's that's the point and if you try
something like g4 that doesn't work
because well of course not win captures
right away allowing rook g3 but first
rook here and now you're in a lot of
trouble
Rubi g3 just Knight captures on e5 and
now it's actually black who's better
so after Quinta is 6 June June 15 g1 and
now we have d4 here attacking the rook
but again pause the video and there is
only one good move for white here so
while I'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding the only
move that wins for the second time in
this video and for those of you who just
want to enjoy a show it's Queen to g6
and now well obviously you cannot
capture the room because of Queen g7
mate you have to prevent mate
Queen to d7 was played just guarding the
square but now the ecigs pushing the
Queen back Quinta c7 and now Queen
captures on h5 just winning the whole
rook and here you're just upper look and
it was in this position on move 45 that
Alexander garage cannot resign the game
and game 3 of the rapids
to June June because you're down the
rook and if you want to recap for a rook
otherwise I mean there's no point in
playing a game being down rook
especially in a position like this
there's there's nothing to do so for
example Queen captures on h6 you cannot
trade Queens because I mean the two
connected path points are too strong and
if you're just f7 check and that's
that's all there is the King has no
squares you have to give up the Queen
and other than that after Queen captures
on h5 there's not much to do you cannot
go here because the rook covers guards
g3 so now I do in June wins Game three
of the rapids and in Game four Jewell
and June was able to hold goralina to a
draw which means after 16 games of the
Women's World Chess Championship match
Julian retains her World Chess
Championship title here there's also a
very nice photo of this moment there we
have it you can see you in June very
happy and the garag Gina of course of
course not very happy as she played
brilliantly in in the classical time
format and well she was better out of
the four games in the rapid she was
better in two and winning in one but all
three ended in a draw and then she lost
this one so definitely a tough break
there's our College work which to the
right I do not know who the woman on the
left of goryeo chicken is so if any we
do know do share so you know I like to
learn stuff as well but yeah tough break
for Gauri Elina but you know there's
always the the second candidates
tournament and there's always the next
water championship cycle which is which
is similar to something that Bobby will
now again again try to achieve so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you've enjoyed this coverage of
the Women's World Chess Championship
match I would like to thank John Knicely
David Kiser or David crisis or maybe
from Germany
for what Sarah golden crystal Urbanek
and the Merion village for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the well whatever
happens next in the chests world at the
moment the Tata Steel masters edition so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent recipe rest of your
Saturday